[Music]
uh
all right so i want to preface this by
saying everybody's played this video so
we'll play it too
this is at aoc's town hall this person
in my opinion
have you seen the video right the eating
babies video uh yes
this person i think is clearly pranking
her did you did you also get this sent
to you
750 times times
you want to play it we might as well may
you raise your hands please
but we're not gonna be here for much
longer because of the
climate crisis we only have a few months
left
i like months we're down to months
she's listen here's the thing she's
clearly pranking her
i don't think she's being sincere i
think this person is
went there to [ __ ] with her she she does
sound a lot like she's doing the celine
dion get them kiosks
i'm just it's my opinion maybe she's
real but i don't think so
for the green deal but it's not oh
somebody pointed out too she's doing the
greta accent too
i think that she's i really do think
that she's [ __ ] with her
get it you know getting rid of fossil
fuel is not going to solve the problem
fast enough
a swedish professor is saying you know
we can eat dead people but that's not
fast enough
so i think your next uh campaign slogan
has to be this we got to start eating
babies
and by the way this is clearly [ __ ]
with her she even has a shirt made she's
clearly [ __ ] i'm actually a little
annoyed at how many um
[Music]
of you people jumped like because i
didn't tweet about this you didn't
really tweet about it right like you
didn't bring this up at all
no people got so people were so quick to
fall for this
like how many people did you see that
were like could you believe this woman
yeah i mean to be fair there were some
people that are already saying this is
this is clearly her [ __ ] i mean
right this is this is like worse acting
than in practical jokers yeah this is
bad
we don't have enough time there's too
much co2
all of you you're you you know you're
pollutant
too much co2 we have to start now please
she had the whole like and also the
other thing with her she's trailing off
because the big reveal was really eat
the babies thing but now she's got
another like minute
and she doesn't she's just trying to
riff you know it's you can always tell
when people don't have experience
speaking to a group yeah i mean because
anybody who has experience speaking in a
group
you're always gonna add uh you're always
gonna put a couple little anecdotes or
something in your pocket
just as a backup it's the same way
you're doing stand-up comedy you're like
i gotta
there's always gonna be that 20 minutes
of hack weed jokes
that are in the [ __ ] they're in a
storage room with dust on them but if
i'm on stage and i'm
like oh [ __ ] so that she didn't have
that
mark dice retweeted this and he's like
she's going to be a queen this weekend
there's a lot of improv comics just go
out there make a name for yourself
so now he's actively calling people to
show up and troll her at these things
at these town hall things that's what
magnets are saying
just go make a name for yourself go out
there so i do hope this turns into um
into something where look there's
certain things you can't do right you
you can't go and you can't threaten
these representatives you can't do any
of that stuff that's only
counter-intuitive and it just gives
them ammo however this
do this to them yeah this is perfectly
legal
you're not breaking any laws show up and
[ __ ] with them not scream at them not
call them k words
not not be be smart about it be funny
what she did i got to give her credit
what she did was what we should
this is a great way we were frustrated
with all these [ __ ] people right all
these people
the the aocs and the and the what's her
name i almost called her
to lip quality yeah no that is
notice positive rapper and uh
and senator one half of black star yeah
house member
um this is what you do fi if you live in
their districts find out where they're
gonna be
show up [ __ ] with them do this stuff
you're allowed to say what you want you
still have free speech [ __ ] with them
like this this is how you [ __ ] with them
you perfectly legal you sound insane and
make it sound like you're supporting
them and just go above and beyond
like i want somebody to show up and want
i want somebody to show up at one at the
beta one and go
not only should we take their guns if
they had a gun we should shoot them in
the head
and just [ __ ] and then eat their guns
yes
we need to eat their guns for the
environment no and
you're right and it's the same way with
the you know the media and i tell people
stop threatening and yelling at the
media
lie to the media make the media think
that there's a busted water main down
at fifth street and make them waste
money taking the van down there and
burning gas there's like little things
you can do
feed them fake new you know legion of
skanks had a great idea about
creating a fake clip of uh podcasters
saying some really crazy [ __ ] and then
feeding it out to the media and being
like
yeah they're scrubbing everything now
it's why you can't really find anything
on the show
and trying to like do fake hit pieces
that they can then reveal or fake
anything you can do to make these people
look like fools
that's not against the rules do it yes
show up at these things be creative
because here's the thing
if you all of these people are
narcissists right
anybody who runs for any this kind of
public office you would agree has has to
have narcissistic tendencies like
you do this a little bit for the money
but you do this for the power
regardless of what you do you have to
you have to be a narcissist to survive
in dc
is law i'm telling you it's way easier
trolling these people if you start by
agreeing with them
agree with something they're you know
what i mean oh yeah of course you got a
pander
pander and they'll let you keep talking
because 99
of the time when aoc or any of these
representatives doesn't have to be a
democrat even even
a it could be a republican one when they
do these town hall things they do it to
get a little bit of press
they're not listening they're hearing
key words so they can go you're right
environment environment environment
so you could probably get look how long
she talked for you could get away saying
this
stuff and not be corrected because all
they heard was you are right
pollutants and it's like a skinny white
woman so they're not gonna do anything
to her because
white women are the biggest victims of
all nobody's gonna grab her by the arm
and get her out of there
yes you are so great i'm so happy that
you're really supporting your great deal
but
it's not enough you know even if we
would bomb russia
we still have too many people she's
clearly [ __ ] kidding
this is she's obviously [ __ ] goddamn
these i mean
i'm 100 [ __ ] you know how many of these
[ __ ] right wingers
sent this to me on ironically all week
oh yeah i know they want to eat pizza to
be fair i did get some people to go i
think she's trolling but you guys should
check it out no but i got some unironic
the left wants to eat babies and i'm
like [ __ ] dude you're
beyond hope too much pollution
so we have to get rid of the babies
that's a big
problem just stopping having babies
decided not
we need to eat the babies under
suspension she's really going hard on
eating the babies she's dedicated she's
a one she's a one issue voter is what
they call him
please give up no thank you thank you
please give a response no thank you
bye-bye we'll go ahead
um okay
she's pat by the way she's look look at
look at aoc's face
she's a little worried she's she could
no we'll go ahead it's no no
so even if she knows she's a troll the
left has pandered themselves
into a position where just in case she's
crazy
they have to cause it because because if
you say something to her and then she
turns out to be crazy you look evil you
know it's okay sweetie
mentally handicapped woman screams at
aoc we should eat babies i know i know
it's okay
thank you so i think um
are they kicking her out yeah no so
one of the things that's very important
to us is that we need to
treat the climate crisis with the
urgency that it does present
um luckily we have more than a few
months
we do need to hit we don't we don't we
don't
luckily we have more than a few months
hey
luckily we have more than a few years
too stop it
the the point is is that you're
dismantling your whole argument because
just like you think a few months is
laughably wrong
a few years is also laughably wrong
zero in several years um
but i think we all need to to
to understand that there are a lot of
solutions that we have
and that we can pursue and that if we
look i'm not against eating babies
if we need to eat babies we'll eat
babies okay
fine you can eat babies do whatever you
want i don't care
just keep me let me just keep this cushy
gig please
we act in a positive way there's i
really want to go back to my
to my luxury apartment in dc can i
please leave this [ __ ]
i ran to be a house member from new york
so i would never have to live in new
york again
no here i am base for hope there's we
are never beyond hope
okay oh we are we've we're way beyond
maybe
but for completely before completely
different it's not the time for hope
oh well i hope i don't get red flags um
confirmed